but the goal to conceal my affidavit
support
hey what yeah he comes Salma green card
Larissa faces deportation while cold
he's moving forward with a new Brazilian
beauty well yes I've only been married
to one resilient divorce and now I'm
dating you dress is way different than a
Reza she's young she's fun she likes to
have a good time I feel like she's a
breath of fresh air she's giving me life
again during the season five premiere of
90-day fiance happily ever after
we got reacquainted with fan favorite
couples as I why are you denying it I've
heard it [ __ ] please and 90 day dad's
were quite frankly just over it I'm
gonna be keeping an eye on this Widow
if he doesn't change his way of doing
what he's doing now he's either gonna
get his ass well boys don't be sent back
to something more hi my 90 day fans fam
its Melissa here let's go ahead and get
into the must-see moments from the
premiere first up cult let the world
know that after his messy divorce from
Larissa he's taken things up a notch or
two
I recall 2.0 he also introduced his new
boo Jessica how are you
thank you my name is Jess and I am 26 oh
I live in Chicago and I okay I live in
stays on the j-1 visa j-1 visa is for
work and study I have been in America
for one year and my GG spiders in six
months but I won't stay America more
because America is amazing okay let's
just talk about cult 2.0 for just a
second
Cole gave us a shower scene this episode
y'all he stepped out of the shower like
look at me now larissa look at me Cole's
really filling himself and I'm here for
it I am here for it alright back to
Jessica now Cole wants to go visit
Jessica in Chicago during this episode
and I listen to everything very closely
everything that she's saying I just you
know have my ears perked up the
statement she made about wanting to stay
in America when Jesus Pires in six
months but I won stay America more
because America is amazing made me
wonder if she's genuinely interested in
Colt or if he's just her key to the
states who knows we have to wait and see
but I will say this colt is making sure
that he does not make the same mistakes
that he has made in the past he's not
trying to rush into this relationship
like he rushed into a relationship with
Larissa when he told Ms Debbie he was
headed to Chicago he told her he was
going to see a friend which didn't sit
well with Jess hey
are you friend no your mom you here we
for friends are you friend I don't tell
my mother everything but that's
irrelevant what's really important is
that he's learned from his past although
the two made plans during their day to
go have some fun in the hotel room
afterwards I'm excited to get late at
night it's been a while Colt did make it
a point to tell Jess that he wants to
take this slow and he wants to be
cautious because he doesn't know her
that well yet
which is the truth this was probably the
best move that Colt could have made
because based off of a sneak preview for
the rest of the season
these two have some major drama in store
wait the world is Vanessa anyway before
that drama comes to our screen let's go
ahead and move on to the next must-see
moment of the night cold cancels
Larissa's green card and it might be a
matter of time before Larissa has the
head back to Brazil old to come sell
mine
orthodoxy supports which means that I
have to find another way to stay here I
have an idea what can happen to me and
I'm very scared to be arrested again and
be deported forever
Larissa's master plan was to come to
America fall in love and eventually
bring her kids here now she tried to do
that with cold the two met online after
about two weeks of spending time
together Colt proposed and then they
later married in June of 2018 now things
went south in January of 2019 when
Larissa was arrested for domestic
battery for an alleged fight between the
two shortly after called file for
divorce and everything was settled in
May of 2019 after their split Larissa
started dating a guy named Eric now
Eric's featured on the show
style sexy young heating dip and dance
but we didn't get through half of the
episode before she dumped him here's why
why did you break up with him we don't
have a sex
nothing's like two friends hanging out
cold tea is different from Erica because
of course you always want to make sex
Araki never complimented me never it
doesn't cost any money to give a
compliment koti always liked your
beautiful iced tea I complain now
larissa did go into detail about what
cult is working with which was a bit TMI
but I get it a man who will still
compliment you after you complain all
day there's a keeper I don't take it as
Larissa mrs. Cole I definitely think she
just misses his attention and she made
that pretty clear
speaking of cult Larissa did open up
about all the work she's had done on her
body since their split laughter I left
Cole's house I lose away IgG but she to
make a bigger I did the Botox IgG my
nosy I did my lips I did my cheekbones I
did my chin I am a new woman and I feel
very happy
okay Larissa 2.0 I'm here for it call an
Larisa have both taken themselves to new
levels I'm curious to know what the
American Dream is for Larissa during the
episode she reached out to her dad in
Brazil and asked him for five thousand
dollars because she wants to start her
green card application and she admitted
that she doesn't have a penny to her
name
but as we see in the sneak previews for
the rest of the season Larissa is
actually preparing to go under the knife
again for what it looks like to be a
boob job so I mean of course it's none
of my business where Larissa chooses to
spend her money or where she chooses to
get her money from but I would be
curious to know what the American Dream
looks like for her in April
ETS lauren zima caught up with Cole and
his mom Debbie and he teased that
Larissa might have a new look I don't
think I recognized her probably on me
that's true notes hope layer be good
probably you
recognize her I haven't seen her so long
maybe she gained weight I don't know
maybe she gained some cold I'm feeling
the shade through the screen cold I
don't know people change their
appearance
the final must-see moment of the night
goes to K Lonnie's dad who had a real
talk with our swellow about stepping up
to be a man for his family they all live
know you are apps there's no half-ass
Haley thank you for your advice in your
concern how are his eyes hopefully you
listen if I get concerned you're gonna
have a problem there's no more dad dad
is fed up he said let me walk off before
I get mad I'm done before I get pissed
off and he walked off Kalani's dad has
been on us well who's back for some time
now just wanting him to step up and be a
man for his family during the episode
Kalani's dad called us well whose job a
teenage job and he also caught us well
you out for going to play volleyball
with his friends basically every day
while Kalani is stuck at home with the
kids now a swellow is 24 and Kalani is
31 so there are a lot of factors that
come into play here
one being maturity level we all know
that women tend to mature faster than
men also a swell ooh mentioned that in
Samoa the women would raise the kids and
clean the house which I might add he
said it's not a tough job
yeah
in the episode there's a moment where
Kalani picks I swell you up from work
and they finally get home instead of
helping Kalani take the kids out of the
backseat I swellow heads to the front
door
meanwhile Kalani is back there
struggling with two kids on her head so
there are definitely some adjustments
that needs to be made based off of the
tease for the rest of the season
Kalani's dad's threat of sending ash
well loop back to Samoa if he doesn't
get his act together mine comes to
fruition I was stupid enough to believe
his words and not watch his actions when
it comes to what we might have in store
for the rest of a couple of this season
know they're hateful angela is headed
back to Nigeria for a potential wedding
with Michael I don't know just
understands the bond that Colt and I
have if she tries to break it she's
gonna be in for a rude awakening and
Colts mom miss Debbie meets Jess do you
want me to come in and build a family
but you don't even recognize me is just
so much ooh we get to catch up with
Sinjin and Tanya it's none of you today
both stop and see what Paul and Carini
have been up to I'm really starting to
worry that cranes I'm happy here in
America
well make sure you stick with ET because
we are covering it all right here see
you next time
[Music]